[Música]
[Aplausos]
bueno pues esta historia es de cómo
conoció el amor de mi vida es una
historia curiosa porque al final todos
nos hacemos esta pregunta en algún
momento de nuestras vidas todos en algún
momento nos preguntamos si realmente
estamos frente al amor de nuestras vidas
o no y yo lo descubrí de una manera
bastante curiosa porque en realidad ni
siquiera me estaba haciendo la pregunta
tenía yo 13 años entonces no me estaba
preguntando eso claramente fue en el año
2003 cuando de repente entré a una sala
de cine y vi una película que se llama
big fish esta película responde justo a
esa pregunta de una manera muy puntual
el director lo que hace es que dice que
cuando tú conoces al amor de tu vida el
tiempo se detiene y entonces tenemos
esta escena maravillosa en donde el
personaje principal está entrando a un
circo y al fondo detrás de una pista
había una mujer rubia y literalmente el
tiempo se detiene entonces yo salí de la
sala del cine totalmente listo y dije ya
ya sé cómo le voy a hacer para conocer
al amor de mi vida tenía 13 años pero no
sabía ni lo que estaba diciendo y fue
justo así lo curioso fue que fue justo
de esa manera tres o cuatro meses
después en una escena bastante similar a
la escena anterior acaba ayudar a rentar
una película con mi mamá llegamos a mi
casa pusimos la película y justo a la
mitad de la película el tiempo se detuvo
igual con palomitas en el aire igualito
me enamoré de los colores me enamoré del
vestuario me enamoré de la música me
enamoré de las actuaciones me enamore un
poquito de nicole kidman también esta
película moulin rouge
y pues justo cuando termine de ver esa
película lo que sucedió fue que se me
pegó una cámara en la mano literalmente
entonces pasé toda mi adolescencia y
toda mi juventud grabando tanta cosa
tuve enfrente grabé todo lo posible ha
habido y por haber
aprendí a dictar
y pues entonces decidí estudiar
comunicación que es una carrera curiosa
y terminando la carrera ya trabajar en
televisa trabajé ahí cuatro años entré
de una manera que no era tal vez la
manera ideal porque entré como diseñador
gráfico que no tenían nada que ver con
agarrar una cámara pero que al final
pues yo sentía que me acercaba al mundo
audiovisual que era lo que yo quería y
pues tenía la esperanza de que en algún
momento me dan la oportunidad de agarrar
una cámara ya de manera profesional
de repente cuatro años después de ser
diseñador gráfico haciendo algo que no
me gustaba
/ un programa que se llamó lo que más
quieres este programa en un programa de
concursos tradicional como el que todos
conocen un reality show entran varias
personas cantan y el ganador se le da un
premio y así fue como conocí atleti
atleti es una
una mujer que trabaja en una casa de una
familia adinerada en boca del río
veracruz
ella se dedica a las labores domésticas
y un día mientras estaba limpiando la
casa
llegó a la sala y en la sala había una
fotografía de las últimas vacaciones que
había tenido la familia de la casa esta
fotografía era una fotografía que
mostraba a los cuatro integrantes de la
familia frente a la torre eiffel
entonces lety tuvo a bien obama al
preguntarle a la señora de la casa que
donde era es el lugar que ella quería
conocerlo y entonces la señora muy
amablemente le contesta lety las gatas
no van a parís
lety no ganó el concurso entonces las
posibilidades de cumplir ese sueño de ir
a parís pues no se veían palpables
todavía
pero al jurado le conmovió tanto la
historia de lety que decidieron
regalarle el viaje a parís donde según
esta historia con la mía leti
para emprender este viaje pero como
ustedes sabrán o si no yo ahora se los
digo en la producción audiovisual todo
es tiempo y todo es dinero entonces
había que hacer esta cápsula o este
proyecto en muy poco tiempo porque tenía
que salir al aire la semana siguiente y
pues no había mucho dinero para mandar a
mucha gente entonces tenía que ir una
única persona esta persona tenía que ser
alguien que supiera editar alguien que
supiera grabar y alguien que pudiera
escribir un guión y dentro de la
producción no había muchas personas con
este perfil por no decir que no había
nadie y yo era el único entonces así es
como le pilló nos emprendemos en un
viaje a parís le team nunca en su vida
se había subido un avión era la primera
vez que subía un avión entonces fueron 8
horas un poco tensas para ambos pero lo
que estuvo muy padre fue que en esas
ocho horas let y yo tuvimos la
posibilidad de conocernos muy
íntimamente ella me platicó la historia
de su vida yo le platiqué la historia de
la mía nos reímos durante ocho horas
lloramos durante ocho horas
y llegamos a parís llegamos a parece un
miércoles más o menos como a las 8 de la
noche agarramos un taxi saliendo del
aeropuerto
una vez que salimos del aeropuerto
fuimos un balotelli y pues los dos
íbamos como perritos buscando la torre
eiffel por las ventanas y pues eso no
sucedió desafortunadamente no nos fuimos
a dormir al día siguiente salimos del
hotel
cuando salimos del hotel se me ocurre la
maravillosa idea de ponerle al led y una
venda en los ojos para que no podía ver
la torre eiffel nos subimos al metro y
entonces cuando estamos bajando de la
estación del tren
nos colocamos justo frente a la torre
eiffel ella con los ojos vendados la
puse de espaldas y esa es la segunda
ocasión en mi vida que el tiempo se ha
detenido afortunadamente no fui tan
tonto y tomé una fotografía que ahora
les voy a enseñar es esa
lety estaba frente a la torre eiffel o
de espaldas de la torre eiffel y el
tiempo se detuvo por completo y ahí fue
donde descubrí que en realidad el
verdadero amor de mi vida es contar
historias después de eso
tuvimos un viaje increíble viajamos 34
días más en donde aprendí a contar una
historia de superación personal que fue
increíble porque al final estaba yo
contando su historia que además había
aprendido de viva voz'
me enamoré de contar historias no solo a
través de la cámara sino
fundamentalmente con mi voz
el tiempo pasó y a raíz de eso he vivido
cosas muy muy locas me di cuenta que si
yo quería contar historias pues tenía
que vivir las entonces viajé por muchos
lugares conocí un chorro de gente que en
mi vida me imaginé conocer
y lo más importante de todo esto es que
he contado cientos y cientos de
historias
creo que tuve la fortuna de tener la
sensibilidad adecuada de saber que si el
tiempo se estaba deteniendo era porque
la vida estaba queriendo indicarme algo
y si no estaba que bien indicara algo
pues tenía que poner especial atención
pues no podía dejarlo pasar tan
fácilmente mi banda favorita tiene una
frase que dice que ahora que soy más
grande mi corazón se ha hecho más frío
hay que voy con esto cuando somos chicos
cuando somos jóvenes o niños somos super
sensibles tan sensibles que si alguien
nos quita una paleta lloramos somos ese
nivel de sensibles conforme vamos
creciendo esa sensibilidad la vamos
perdiendo y el mundo ha normalizado que
perdamos esa sensibilidad lo que no nos
damos cuenta es que tener esa
sensibilidad nos da muchas respuestas a
las preguntas que le hacemos a la vida
gracias
[Aplausos]